[Music] Is
it a cursed dance or
something? It's a luxury to be able to use your hair freely like this.
Well, the rest is over there. I often notice that. Compared to that, if my husband doesn't do it, he should
go somewhere else.
Thank you very much.  I do
n't have enough. What is this? Cacao. If you don't have enough, all you have to do is
prepare it. But you can
get it in the west, further south. If you look for the attacking items, you'll
find them.
[Music] That's
all you need. Milk, butter, sugar, honey, and powdered cacao.  That's enough, they're all high-end items.
What on earth are you going to make? It's not a snack, you
guys. What are you doing? Go back to your work.
Now it's time for beauty.
Maomao
[Music]
Ah, Yokoshima's customer gave it to his popular daughter-in-law to get her attention, but
unfortunately he ended up being banned by the hot-headed old man. It's
all good. We'll just have to wait for it to harden. It's a little bit.
Well, with this, there's no need to refrigerate it.
Maybe I'll just wash it under the umbrella. Hey, I've been too obsessed with medicinal herbs here and there, so it's getting
late. Tae, I
know the potency anyway, so I don't
mind if you ask me what I mean.  The DET I was showing